le gel désinfectant dans les lieux
publics est il moins systématiquement
utilisé en général quand je fais les
magasins je le fais dans la première
boutique après les boutiques d'après par
les mains et les marckois entrée au
magasin m'a désinfecte parce que on
touche à tout picchu fait que je suis
prêt afin de désinfecter les mains je
fais quand il a marqué une quand c'est
devant moi et la pancarte avec marc est
obligatoire et devant sinon je le fais
pas vraiment de leur côté certains
commerçants constatent encore une bonne
utilisation du produit honnêtement c'est
au choix mais je vois que 8 de 10
clients vont l'utiliser encore
aujourd'hui au tout début on faisait
très attention on était très vigilant là
on est un petit peu moins mais quand
même ouais je dirais bien les deux tiers
des personnes voient en fait avec les
bidons que la quantité diminue donc ça
continue à être utilisée quand même il y
est né ce piqûre commandes toujours le
lavage des mains à l'eau et au savon
mais pour ce qui est du gel désinfectant
son utilité est questionnable un
contexte actuel
ça sera au gouvernement de décider s'il
continue ou pas recommander le gel
désinfectant mais pour ce qui est de la
transmission de la coved 19 ses premiers
pas ce qui va changer grand chose il
convient de 19,2 propage principalement
par gouttelettes très peu de chances de
l'attraper en touchant des objets dans
un commerce quant à l'utilisation du
plexiglas selon plusieurs virologues son
utilisation doit être faite au cas par
cas par exemple il est recommandé en
pharmacie puisque les patients parfois
malades interagissent avec les employés
l'important c'est qu'il soit bien
installé dans une salle 26 loupé ce gars
eux au moins empêcher que vous avez un
flot direct de particules virales qui
sont dans l'air et puis que vous pouvez
ingérée
l'utilisation du gel désinfectant
demeurent bons réflexes bien que c est
fait pour freiner la propagation de la
comédie 19 demeurent négligeables
contrairement au port du masque ici ma
qu'isabel rochât radio canada montréal